[Music]
welcome back if you're wondering what
the difference between Body Sculpting
and say liposuction is well facet Body
Sculpting the sponsors of this segment
can help break it all down for us so
joining us now is Doug Zuko Doug thank
you for coming back and seeing us thanks
for having me so let's talk a little bit
overall about what you do at fastfit and
maybe some misconceptions and how it
differs from other treatments let's talk
about liposuction because liposuction is
invasive it can get to only one layer of
fat so we basically have two types of
fat on our body we have subcutaneous fat
which is the outside fat and they have
visceral fat which is that deep belly
fat and I think we might have there's a
diagram right so subcutaneous fat the
fat on the outside whatever you can
pinch the Jiggles that's the only thing
that liposuction can get to okay the
visceral fat it cannot touch so visceral
fat is usually the problem and that's we
pride ourselves on it at fasted because
we can do both yeah so how do you get to
that visceral fat you got to get that
stuff out of there right absolutely
right we want to reduce both okay so you
know by liposuction they only get to the
outside it's invasive there's a lot of
risk as far as uh infection anesthesia
all that right so we have no risk
everything we do is really healthy at
fast fit but what we do is the
technology activates receptors in the
fat cells to help the fat cells empty
out so we're not destroying any fat
cells okay because when you destroy fat
cells you destroy stem cells and you do
not want to do that so we have some
before and after photos to really put
into perspective of the work that that
you guys do so we're going to pull them
up now I mean this is just the first one
and it's amazing what are we looking at
here well Cameron she had some type of
procedure done before coming to fast fit
you can see that little dent in her
lower belly right where some fat was
removed and just look the difference
this is 15 pounds later come to fast fit
all evened out looks amazing wow that is
unbelievable and just one of the few
that we have here let's pull up our next
one here I think is this Dawn Dawn and
age 60 same thing had a procedure it was
a little lumpy there got it all
straightened out look how amazing her
skin looks wow
all right moving on next to Vera I think
we have and bear is very petite right
right only five and a half pounds of fat
gone but look at the difference and look
at the difference in the skin you won't
see any any of that happen with other
technology yeah even five and a half
pounds that's incredible and also
helpful to know that you treat all
different sizes so that's a prime
example of that I think we have one more
here wow
we can't let the men out right we can't
leave the men out it's incredible Jose
23 pounds of fat gone looks amazing
picture speaks for itself wow it's
unbelievable and really quickly after
this is done do you have to worry about
sagging or loose skin or anything like
that never you can I mean fast fit
actually helps build collagen of the
skin so it's amazing twofold for the
skin I mean it's amazing wow well Doug
thank you so much for being here and
breaking it all down really seeing those
pictures puts it into
so
that for sponsoring this segment call
1-800 fastfit or visit fast.fit and they
have a special offer the first 20
callers can get up to 60 off their
services we'll be right back
[Music]